there's a new highway in pakistan
and a new rail terminal in kazakhstan
a seaport in sri lanka recently opened
as well as this bridge in rural laos
what's interesting is that they're all
part of one country's project
that spans three continents and touches
over 60 percent of the world's
population
if you connect the dots it's not hard to
see which country that is this is
china's belt and road initiative
the most ambitious infrastructure
project in modern history
that's designed to reroute global trade
and it's how china plans to become the
world's next superpower
[Music]
it's 2013 and chinese president xi
jinping is giving a speech in kazakhstan
where he mentions the ancient silk road
a network of trade routes that spread
goods ideas and culture across
europe the middle east and china as far
back as 200 bc
he then says we should take an
innovative approach
and
[Music]
should work together to build up a new
maritime
road in the 21st century these two
phrases were the first mentions of g's
legacy project
the multi-trillion dollar belt and road
initiative or bri
they're also the two components of the
plan there's an overland economic belt
of six corridors that serve as new
routes to get goods in and out of china
like this railroad connecting china to
london and these gas pipelines from the
caspian sea to china
and a high-speed train network in
southeast asia
then there's the maritime silk road a
chain of seaports stretching from the
south china sea to africa that also
directs trade to and from china
the bri also includes oil refineries
industrial parks power plants mines and
fiber optic networks
all designed to make it easier for the
world to trade with china
so far over 60 countries have reportedly
signed agreements for these projects
and the list is growing because china
promotes it as a win-win for everyone
take for example the bri's flagship
project pakistan
like many countries in central and south
asia pakistan has a stagnant economy and
a corruption problem
it wasn't a popular place for foreign
investment that is until china came
along
in 2001 china offered to build a brand
new port in the small fishing town of
guadar
by 2018 the port as well as a highway
and railway networks
became a 62 billion corridor within the
bri
it's where the economic belt meets the
maritime silk road
and it seemed to benefit both countries
pakistan saw its highest gdp growth in
eight years
and forged a tight relationship with a
major world power
china on the other hand secured a new
alternative route for goods especially
oil and gas from the middle east
through projects like these it also
found a way to boost its economy
chinese construction companies that had
fewer opportunities within their own
country
saw a huge boost from bri contracts
seven
of the 10 biggest construction firms in
the world are now chinese
what tips the balance in china's favor
even more is a requirement that it be
involved in building these projects
in pakistan for example chinese workers
have directly built projects like this
highway here and a chinese firm has
worked with locals on a railway here in
serbia
china's involvement is one of its very
few demands and that's set these deals
apart so far
see typically to get investment from the
west countries have to meet strict
ethical standards but china's offered
billions of dollars
mostly in loans with far fewer
conditions
so it's no surprise the bri has been a
big hit with the less democratic
countries in the region
china has signed agreements with
authoritarian governments military
regimes
and some of the most corrupt countries
in the world it's even affiliated with
afghanistan ukraine
yemen and iraq all currently splintered
by conflict
because of china's willingness to loan
money to unreliable countries
many experts have called the bri a risky
plan
eventually these countries will have to
pay china back but corruption and
conflict make that payback
unlikely a recent report found that many
of the countries indebted to china are
very vulnerable
including eight that are at high risk of
being unable to pay
so why does china keep lending because
there's more to the bri than just
economics in sri lanka china loaned
about 1.5 billion dollars for a new
deepwater port
it was a key stop on the maritime silk
road by 2017 it was clear sri lanka
couldn't pay back the loan
so instead they gave china control of
the port as part of a 99-year lease
china also controls the strategic port
in pakistan where it has a 40-year lease
it's pushing for a similar agreement in
myanmar and it just opened an actual
chinese naval base in djibouti
these are all signs of what's been
called the string of pearls theory
it predicts that china is trying to
establish a string of naval bases in the
indian ocean
that will allow it to station ships and
guard shipping routes that move through
the region
so while china's not getting its money
back it's still achieving some very
important strategic goals
china's growing influence challenges the
status of the us
which has been the world's lone
superpower for the last several decades
but isolation is trending in the us
meaning that they are investing less and
therefore losing influence around the
world
the bri is china's way of leveraging
power to become a global leader
by building relationships and taking
control of global trade
china's well on its way
[Music]
you